il était une fois une paire de sneakers
là où vivait un garçon plein de
créativité et il s'imagine que les
smicards sont une fenêtre sur l'amour je
crois que si tu mets assez de toi même
dans un design ça cartonne
dès que j'enfile ces sneakers
elle devienne mon histoire mais pour
beaucoup ces rêves peuvent sembler aussi
inaccessible qu'un château dans les
nuages
sa majesté des sneakers travailler pour
la marque king tu veux dire c'est mon
rêve on doit dominer le marché là on a
besoin d'un gros coup il nous faut une
nouvelle voie quelques uns des nouveaux
trouve un créateur digne d'intérêt qui
te plaît qui raconte une histoire
maintenant on doit les retrouver
un garçon vraiment très tôt je
gribouille dans mon carnet je suis
magasinier c'est drôle on croirait
entendre ton beau père on est dans le
monde réel et lit pas dans ses
gribouillages où ces bêtises auquel tu
passes ton temps à rêver
et arrange ça aussi
il s'accrochait à ses rêves même si le
monde autour de lui dans tes à toute
force de lui remettre les pieds sur
terre le gala de charité de qu'inwi
dessine des super chaud sur le plat ce
sens
allez tu as des sneakers a créé
m c'est
qui
bien travaillé et est prêt pour le grand
soir
oui vu ça
désolé
cestjoelle c'est toi qui les a créés
c'est toi l'artiste dans tout le monde
parle et si ce soir mais je dois le
faire sortir des sites de suite qu'on
attendait
devenir ses rêves
enfin j'en suis encore à quai
il serait alors dotée d'une magie toute
particulière n'est ce pas
[Musique]